living my life so i go to heaven and
never come back i had a weird experience
and i don't really know what to call it
i basically i felt like i was visited by
some beings in my room
and then um
yeah and then i i traveled and
uh with that being said like i i sound
quite out there it was this bright light
it kind of moved in like these weird
ways demi claims they were taken by
alien beings while on a trip to joshua
tree the 29 year old singer says they
went willingly and communicated
telepathically with the beings they call
their light doctors i feel like we're
all our own worst enemy or at least i am
and
so i i definitely
could see
how if anything is up there watching
over me they're definitely trying to
protect me from my worst enemy images
myself can you at least say hello to
demi
oh
the shocking revelation is made in
demi's new four-part docu-series
unidentified with demi lovato debuting
thursday on peacock the series includes
demi's sister dallas and best friend
matthew montgomery together they
investigate abduction stories and talk
to ufo experts demi even undergoes
hypnosis to recall their own experience
where do you fall on the belief
skepticism the whole thing i have a very
open mind you know but this was this was
unlike anything
that i've ever experienced yes before we
shot the show i was a skeptic and now
since we've shot it i haven't stopped
talking about it what if they're already
here waiting for us to reach out i was
like are cameras recording this are you
are you and i think demi dad's like yeah
this is a tv show we're filming i was
like good because i cannot believe what
is happening right now
whoa
oh
did you just
yo yo hold the phone the one time where
we were like uh
you looked up we looked up and we were
about to shoot and like everybody was
setting up the cameras and you were you
guys are like they're right there like
literally
you know that was crazy there would
certainly be times where we like asked
them to turn off lights so we could see
the sky better and then
we pretty much forgot that the cameras
were there in a way so much was
happening especially in arizona that was
kind of like okay forget about all this
we need to talk about what's going on
what is that oh my goodness wait this is
so crazy people are skeptical of aliens
right they they don't want to believe
you could have kept this to yourself
this whole event that happened to you
but you didn't why is that important
i think it's important for me to talk
about my experience so that more people
don't feel alone in their experiences
i feel like
it's so important also to talk about
this because it freezes our
consciousness you know it expands our
consciousness and that's what we have to
do
in order to make this world a better
place
[Music]
you